>> IT'S CONTRADICTION CITY OVER
BIDEN'S DOCUMENT DRAMA.
THE SECRET SERVICE IS READY TO
TURN OVER WHO VISITED BIDEN'S
DELAWARE HOME.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE SAID THOSE
LOGS DIDN'T EXIST.
A GOOD QUESTION TO ASK
KARINE-JEAN PIERRE.
>> I ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION.
>> NO YOU DIDN'T.
>> THAT'S YOUR OPINION.
>> I JUST SAID TO YOU THE WHITE
HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE WILL
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION.
>> ARE YOU NOT GOING TO BE
TAKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
>> I HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
WE WILL BE PRUDENT.
>> WHY --
>> IT'S NOT YOUR DECISION TO
MAKE WHAT I CAN OR CAN'T MAKE.
>> YOU CAN SEE WHY THE WHITE
HOUSE REPORTERS HAD ENOUGH OF
KARINE-JEAN PIERRE.
MEMBERS CALL HER BRIEFINGS
A PAINFUL WASTE OF TIME.
JESSE WATTERS GETS HIS HANDS ON
NEW HUNTER BIDEN PHOTOS SHOWING
THE DISGRACED FIRST SON CRUISING
AROUND IN JOE'S PRIZED CORVETTE
OUTSIDE OF THE GARAGE.
HE IS DRIVING WITH THE BLURS.
THEY ARE A FAMILY OF BLURRED
PEOPLE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> THAT WAS HIS NIECE AND HER
FRIEND.
THEY WERE DRESSED TO GO TO THE
BEACH.
THIS WAS RIGHT AROUND THE TIME
HE WAS CUTTING A DEAL WITH THE
CHINESE FOR $6 MILLION TO THE
BIDEN FAMILY.
THE TIME THE DOCUMENTS WERE FROM
THE GARAGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE DOOR WAS
OPEN OR CLOSED.
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
AT THIS TIME HE HAD NO SECRET
SERVICE DETAIL BETWEEN THE TIME
HE WAS VP AND THE COMNY.
-- NOMINEE.
WHO KNOWS WHO WAS IN AND OUT OF
THE GARAGE?
THEY SAY THEY DON'T HAVE LOGS.
THEY MIGHT HAVE A RECORD OF THE
POOL OR THE PIZZA GUY THAT COMES
IN.
BUT IF SOMEONE COMES OVER TO
WALKED GAME TO TALK STOCKS WITH
HUNTER THEY DON'T JOT HIS NAME
DOWN.
REMEMBER BILL CLINTON WHEN
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD LEAVE AND
5 MINUTES LATER THE MISTRESS
WOULD SHOW UP.
THIEVE
THIEVES -- SHE WAS NOT ON ANY
VISITOR LOG.
>> EXCELLENT REPORTING.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> JESSICA, YOU SAID THAT YOU
ARE FED UP WITH KARINE-JEAN
PIERRE.
WHY ARE YOU SUCH A RACIST
HOMOPHOBE?
>> OH!
GREG, I WASN'T EXPECTING THAT.
THAT WASN'T IN THE TELEPROMPTER.
IT'S BEEN HANDLED POORLY FROM
A COMMUNICATION STANDPOINT.
IF IT'S A DOJ PROBLEM, THEN
DEMAND A DOJ SPOKESPERSON SHOW
UP.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
UPSETTING TO DEMOCRATS THAT HE
HAD THEM WHEN HE WAS NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE THEM AND WE
HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT THE TIMELINE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT I
BELIEVE IS COMPARABLE TO WHAT
WENT ON WITH FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP BECAUSE HE HAD TO STALKED
TO GET DOCUMENTS BACK.
JAY BRAD HAD TO SHOW UP AT
MAR-A-LAGO BECAUSE THEY SAID WE
RETURNED AND EVERYTHING THEY
HADN'T.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
COOPERATING.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE THOSE DETAILS
CLEAR SO PEOPLE HAVE FAITH IN
THE FACT THAT YOU HANDLED IT AS
RESPONSIBLY AS POSSIBLE.
STUFF HAPPENS.
YOU MOVE OUT OF OFFICES.
AND YOU SHOULD RETURN THEM WHEN
YOU FIGURE THAT OUT.
STONE WALLING AND SAYING I WON'T
ANSWER THAT, YOU LEAVE PEOPLE TO
THEIR IMAGINATIONS AND IT'S NOT
GREAT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE IS SUPPOSED
TO ANNOUNCE HE IS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
>> JUDGE, IS THIS THE EFFECT
FROM THE DEMOCRATS TO KEEP HIM
FROM LAUNCHING?
>> I THINK I SAID THIS LAST
WEEK.
THIS WOULD BE THE DEMOCRATS
SAYING WE HAVE TO GET THIS
GEEZER OUT OF THE WAY.
I HAVE TO RESPOND, JESSICA.
YOU SAID IT WAS SO MUCH WORSE
THAN TRUMP.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TRUMP AND
BIDEN.
TRUMP COULD DECLASSIFY.
BIDEN COULD NOT.
HE THE RECORDS FOR 6 YEARS!
THEY WERE FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
BIDEN HAD THEM IN A PLACE PAID
FOR BY THE CHINESE.
$50-MILLION.
IN ADDITION TO THAT.
BIDEN WAS NOT HONEST WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY KNEW ON NOVEMBER 2ND THEY
HAD CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FOUND
BY LAWYERS WHO AT NIGHT TIME
MOVED THEM WITH NO CLEARANCE.
THEN THEY FOUND STUFF ON
DECEMBER 20th.
BUT THEY TOLD US ON JANUARY
NINTH THEY WERE NOT HONEST THEY
ALSO HAD STUFF FROM DECEMBER
20th.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A QUESTION OF
THEM HANDLING POORLY.
IT'S A QUESTION OF THEM HANDLING
IT DISHONESTLY.
ANOTHER THING.
I THINK KARINE-JEAN PIERRE, IF
SHE HAD ANY RESPECT FOR HERSELF
AND HER OWN CAREER SHE WOULD SAY
DO NOT SEND ME OUT IN FRONT OF
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC LOOKING LIKE
I AM COVERING UP, LYING OR I AM
AN IDIOT.
YOU TELL ME OR GIVE ME SOMEONE
TO REFER THEM TO.
>> HOLD ON A SECOND.
HOLD THAT THOUGHT.
DANA, MY MILLION DOLLARS
QUESTION.
PRESS SECRETARY OF STATE ARE
A SMALL CLUB AND FEMALES EVEN
SMALLER BECAUSE THEY WEIGH LESS.
HAASE KARINE-JEAN PIERRE EVER
REACHED OUT TO YOU SAY TO I NEED
HELP?
>> NO, SHE HAS A LOT OF FRIENDS
AND SUPPORTERS.
SHE COULD CALL ANY MEMBER OF THE
GROUP LIKE JEN PSAKI.
WHAT THE JUDGE SAID IS VERY
CORRECT.
BIDEN ALLOWED THIS WOMAN TO GO
OUT THERE.
THEY DIDN'T TELL HER.
I BELIEVE WHEN SHE SAID HE
DIDN'T KNOW.
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE WAS IN
A COVER-UP IF SHE DID KNOW.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW.
SO YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU ARE
TALKING B. YOU DON'T HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE OF THE CHIEF OF
STAFF.
THEY LET HER TWIST IN THE WIND
EVERY DAY.
WHERE IS KAMALA HARRIS?
HELP A SISTER OUT.
IF I WERE KAMALA HARRIS I WOULD
GO TO THE CHIEF OF STAFF'S
OFFICE AND TO BIDEN SAY TOMORROW
SOMEBODY FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO HELP HER
OUT.
YOU ARE RUINING HER ABILITY TO
HAVE COMMAND IN THE ROOM.
WHEN WHITE HOUSE REPORTERS TALK
TO THE PRESS ABOUT HOW UNHAPPY
THEY ARE IT'S HARD TO I CANNING
OUT OF THAT.
A CONSTRUCTION SITE WILL SAY 80
DAYS WITHOUT A SAFETY INCIDENT.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS ZERO DAYS OF
PROVIDING INACCURATE
INFORMATION.
PART IS HER FAULT.
SHE HAS TO PROTECT HERSELF.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF AND THE
CHIEF OF STAFF OWE SOMETHING
BETTER THAN WHAT THEY HAVE
PROVIDED.
THEY ARE MAKING HER JOB SO MUCH
HARDER.
>> A LAST WORD?
>> THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
TRUM